Uh, do you want to see what weaponized ignorance
looks like? This is a term that applies to
the current American president of very precisely
and so much that it's sometimes scary. Uh,
and I'm going to set this up for you today.
So Trump puts new tariffs on China again starting
today. Trump says, if China retaliates with
tariffs because of our tariffs, then he will
do even more tariffs, which is exactly why
trade wars are not fun and not easy to win.
So early this morning, Trump puts out tweets
that once again put in doubt whether he is
good at English. And it definitely rules out
that he knows anything about economics. This
is a two tweet comment. That's one of Trump's
dumbest. If you look at the content of it.
Okay, Trump says they're t, H, e. I. R. T.
H. E. I. R. There is no reason for the US
consumer to pay the tariffs, which take effect
on China today. This has been proven recently
when only four points were paid by the u s
21 points by China because China subsidizes
product is such a large degree. Also, the
tariffs can be completely avoided if you buy
B Y, but from a non tariffed country or you
buy the product inside the USA, the best idea,
that's zero tariffs. Many tariff companies
will be leaving China for Vietnam and other
such countries in Asia. That's why China wants
to make a deal so badly. So the grammar and
spelling mistakes are, are at this point.
These are things we learned when we were eight
years old. I remember the conversation in
third grade where we talked about, um, uh,
they're, they're, they're, uh, and to, to
end by, by, and how all of this works.
And Trump is publicly commenting on trade
policy with embarrassingly bad English. And
it's a continued embarrassment around the
world. But then let's really dig into the
content because that's what matters. Most.
Trump doesn't understand that American consumers
pay the tariffs on China one way or the other.
Trump's economic adviser, Larry Kudlow, a
far right winger, went on Fox News and admitted
that economists and businesses are correct,
that we paid Trump's tariffs. Trump genuinely
thinks that China pays the tariffs, so he
believes he's punishing them with the terrorists.
Take some item. Aluminum, for example, that
China sells to us. American companies build
stuff with aluminum. When they buy Chinese
aluminum, they start to pay a tariff on it,
on that aluminum to the United States government,
right? The American company pays the tariff
to the American government on the Chinese
aluminum. The Chinese company still just gets
paid for the aluminum.
Since the American company had to pay a tariff
on the aluminum, they will add to the cost
of that tariff to the finished product, whether
it's a car or a house or other products that
are made from aluminum, and so the American
consumer in the end pays the tariff. The idea
is, as Trump suggests, if the tariffs are
high enough, it will make American companies
and American consumers get their aluminum
from American companies instead, but in reality
it's just not that simple. Very often the
products that are tariffed aren't available
as easily in the United States or the cost
difference is still so great that it still
is cheaper to pay the tariff on the foreign
stuff and keep buying the foreign stuff, which
is just a net negative for American consumers
and American corporations. This is a red alert
because Donald Trump thinks that tariffs are
a good idea because he doesn't know how they
actually work.
He is destroying the economy with these tariffs
that have no off ramp there only escalating,
not deescalating, and he thinks that they
work in a completely different way than they
actually do. He has to be stopped. He has
to be removed. And the easiest and most direct
path is just voting him out in November of